i'm here to co-pilot a dear friend of
the show and someone i absolutely love
the lovely roth
ross matthews oh there goes the list
ross matthews
and you know we totally coordinate
totally on accident
i just think it's a basher it meant to
be totally understand
i mean literally we do not call each
other about these outfits and yet
here we are we are always coordinated
right here's it
i love it this is a really good story
tis the season for cozying up with a
hallmark holiday movie and having a good
cry this time of year i love hallmark
movies i mean they're really all the
rage
every all the feels in one movie all the
fields
and this weekend hallmark made history
with the christmas house
usa today reports that it's their first
holiday movie to feature
a gay couple hello hello
i know right stars brad hardner
and jonathan bennett from mean girls as
a couple adopting a child
and starting their own family and by the
way
it is about time how great to see this
kind of thing i remember being a little
kid growing up
in a little farm town not even knowing
like a gay grown-up human being looked
like let alone if we could find
love and now look there's a hallmark
movie about us
it's just i'm so proud of hallmark you
know the gays have been supporting you
hallmark for a long time thanks for
supporting us
yeah yeah we can all make each other
feel welcomed
it's just so wonderful so i'm i'm really
happy about it
drew barrymore preach
now ross for many people thanksgiving is
going to be
virtual this week so the cut
one of my favorites shared this zoom
thanksgiving tip they say
okay you should designate a turkey day
host
yeah i like that i thought it was very
actionable your thanksgiving
mc should be a good talker someone who
can drive conversation
and reduce zoom awkwardness uh-huh i
agree if you have somebody sort of
running the show
and so it's time to make a toast now
what dish do you
have it could be a lot of fun well also
one thing that i
live for on thanksgiving is to go around
the table and say what we're thankful
for
and to watch my kids over the years like
really grow into that you know position
my aunt was a um like an elementary
school teacher so she would like make us
out of construction paper little buckles
for our shoes like pilgrims and cute
little
i sell pictures god i was a cute kid
yeah well i don't think you were ross
well i'm a cute grown-up kid
oh you're not so bad yourself you know
with so many people having small at-home
gatherings this year
turkey farmers are really worried
because they've got a surplus
of big old birds and you know you know
we do i like big birds and i cannot lie
that was like a dog
there we go i found it
there we go there you go you're going to
keep doing that all day all right
the washington post reports turkey
farmers they plan you know
months ahead of time yeah and they get
all these big birds because usually what
you want like a 20 pound bird
but now since people aren't gathering
they all want like a little itty bitty
you know
little bird so what do they do with all
these huge turkeys the toms they call
them i was gonna say they call them the
toms
i made my first turkey several years ago
yeah and your first jerky you never
forget because you're convinced you're
gonna like just ruin everything
and it was the best turkey i've ever
made i also uh
slathered it head to toe in bacon what
and cooked it so all the salt went in
from that bacon and that bird was gone
way too quickly and then i didn't have
any leftovers
so maybe going big this year is you know
a better way to do it and then you won't
waste the turkey
and i'm fine if you make a big one just
eat it all week
long all right that's the best part
overs are the greatest and there's never
enough left enough so maybe the toms
will solve the leftover issues
thank you tom thank you tom
well ross speaking of cooking i wanted
to test your culinary prowess with a
little
special recipe challenge yes because you
know i cook on my instagram all the time
i call them recipes oh i know that's why
we wanted to have the honor and pleasure
of doing a recipe here on this show
well wait till you taste it i don't know
how much pleasure will be involved
because you
really set me up to barrymore well it
was sort of like a chop challenge
earlier i asked you to preface a
thanksgiving dish with a twist
you had to make something thanksgivingy
and use a ton of random ingredients we
picked so
let's find out and take a look at how
you did oh no
i'm excited
hi drew hi hi it's me ross all right you
have given me a recipe thanksgiving
challenge and i am just the man
for the job in here is a list of
ingredients you put together i don't
know what these are
but i'm gonna shop for them here and
then make some sort of thanksgiving
inspired dish
let's see what you've given me eggnog
okay
pumpkin pie edamame stuffing that i have
to not use as stuffing
yucca what what the
yuca all right a thai chili pepper
and spam oh girl you're not making this
easy on me but i'm up for the challenge
let's go inside okay this list is
no joke drew that's a lot of peppers but
okay everybody in this grocery store is
looking at me like oh he's such a ham
eggnog got it um what's next
drew i'm glad you didn't email me this
list because it could have gone in my
spam folder
okay beans here we go maybe i could use
them like peas and something
oh how about them apples okay here's a
pumpkin pie
what what this is frozen yucca
honestly i don't know what to do
[Applause]
i have too much guilt i have too much i
have to put it back
look stuffing this is what i need it's
on the list
i think i just had an idea so we're in
the kitchen now and we're about to cook
this
recipe thanksgiving challenge i'm
thinking
a savory pie now i've cut up my yucca
into little small uh pieces
okay eggnog yuca mashed potato-ness
let's go just so we can know what we're
dealing with
[Music]
voila i cleaned out pie crust
okay oh so they're like fine bread
crumbs now
[Music]
bon appetit
here it is i brought it in and are you
going to try it
i have to tell you ross this looks
really good yeah it looks good i don't
know how it's going to taste
well have you tasted it yet mm-hmm
i am telling you it looks good all right
here we go ready
two
this is good she said it's good people
she said it's good
you guys i'm so relieved this is amazing
you know what maybe it's a new
thanksgiving classic you're welcome
america
do you want to try one of these i love
when like you kind of blow your
doors off and get your lips i did one
you think i could do another one let's
do it
oh no okay three two
[Applause]
why are we doing this because i just
felt like fun oh my god
thank you ross i love your recipe and i
love you perfection thanksgiving
recipe and happy thanksgiving to you